so as Adam described another postdoc
researcher at Microsoft Research and
most of my research is in understanding
the relationship between prediction and
causation so what I'm going to do in
this talk is to just give a very very
broad overview of why we should care
about causal inference and I'll give you
examples on why it should we should and
then I'll also try to show you that it's
not just that it's good in a very
academic sense because you're you feel
happier if you know the causes it's also
helpful to evaluate the systems that we
build like recommendation systems and
it's actually also useful to make
predictions more robust and I think the
goal for this stock would be the sort of
mainly focus on why we should care
because I'll show you a lot of examples
where you can get really really bad
results if you're not careful about that
and I'm hoping that with that motivation
there are lots of other tools that I'll
point to which can help in points second
and third so I'll just sort of briefly
go over the point second and third but
really the goal of this talk is to
understand why should we care especially
when we have increasing amounts of data
we have data about all the properties
all the users about any online system if
you have access to the logs and we can
do really good predictions I mean this
conference I guess it doesn't need to be
said that there are lots of machine
learning advances that are helping us
make create predictions so here's some
examples we can recommend people what to
buy what to wear who to date we can find
fake activities we can find fraudulent
activities in money markets and we can
also give really really good search
results right so in terms of prediction
if you give me a problem and say that
this is what I want to predict we are
very successful and so let's just with
good a few seconds on how this
prediction work very very bare-bones for
you suppose you have a problem of
finding out which users will contribute
more to your platform in the future
right so these are Xbox users so maybe
at Microsoft we want to know which you
we'll play more games in the future and
which would not right and so one day
answer would be that let's just make it
a prediction problem so we collect a lot
of features about the users maybe their
age gender past activity social network
and so on and then we can simply say
that the final activity is just a
prediction function of their earlier
activities right and this is what we
find in practice so if you look at this
user they have a lot of friends and if
you look at the other user who have
lower activity they have no friends
right so if I make a prediction
algorithm that just takes the number of
friends and the logins in the past month
I can predict with really good accuracy
who's going to come back in the next
month right and this is almost like a
solved problem you can get packages to
do it but the question then becomes once
we've made this prediction so what if I
was doing this and I would take this to
my boss they would ask me this question
so that's good okay so we know that
people have more friends than they play
more what do I do with it how do I now
make more people claim more games on
xbox because that's what my boss wants
to do so here's the den causal question
then comes up right we're increasing the
number of friends increase activity on
Xbox right it's clearly predicts well
it's very high accuracy but do we know
that well think of let's think about it
right so if it's the case that having
more friends makes you much more likely
to play more because you feel a part of
the community yes right and this is what
this model is showing each node is
essentially a variable so here number of
friends and each arrow shows the
direction of causal connection so this
graph essentially is saying number of
friends causes Xbox activity great but
what if it's the opposite what if all
that's happening is that just the people
who play a lot of games are also make a
lot of friends just because they're
playing games and while playing games
they meet new people if that's the case
then our model
may not really help that much and what's
insidious is that maybe both of them are
not true really something else is
happening like what's maybe happening is
that they're just these some people who
like playing games and if you give an
xbox to them they'll both play a lot of
games and make a lot of friends but if
there are the other kinds of people who
have an Xbox they would do neither of
those things and any effort to increase
their friends or any effort to increase
their activity would not affect any of
the outcomes and so really the key
question becomes that once we have these
models how do we know what causes what
and this doesn't happen in just about
Xbox systems or prediction systems in
the next couple of examples I'm going to
show that this is sort of a problem
endemic to the whole online system and
online platforms world so let's take
search engines right if you read any
marketing journal or article they will
say that search ads are the best they
get about the highest CTR compared to
display ads and any other ads that you
can think of right so this seems like
greater search ads really work well but
again do they really so if you want to
predict when a user searches for Amazon
toys what is the most relevant ad to
show to them we are very very accurate
right you can try this for most queries
I'm sure a lot of you have noticed this
the ads would be really relevant and
once I see an ad for Amazon toy at
amazon.com that's exactly what I wanted
and I would click on it right and so in
some sense you might think that wow
you're getting high click throughs but
the question again begs what's the
counterfactual right what would have
happened if Amazon did not pay Bing for
those ads and instead the user was just
forced to look at the organic search
results well the answer is they would
have also seen the same links in the
organic search results and so it's a
sort of an empirical question to what
extent are these ads actually helping
Amazon gain new customers right and if
you can want to think of the graphical
model again and this is very nice
because thinking of in terms of
graphical model
helps us expose these sort of
complicated procedures and do very very
simple principles so it could be that
search add causes visits to toy website
great then you should spend a lot of
time and money on Bing ads good for
Microsoft do but it could be just
happening that it's just a search query
right there are some people who are
interested in toys they issue search
queries they are more likely to click on
the search ad they're also more likely
to go to the toy website anyways and
then there are just lots of other people
who are not interested in toys
maybe that's the ones you want to show
ads to but if you use this approach
you're not gonna get them but you'll
still get a high CTR right so the whole
point of this example is that when we
look at observational metrics I mean
when we look at how great our models are
at predicting what a user will do they
are good at exactly that but they are
not good at the counterfactual what
would her user have done if we had not
spent money on this item or if he not
had this new feature that we booked and
so you might think that there are some
concocted cases like these in search and
recommendations but actually they apply
almost anywhere so even if you look at
offline ads like display bull Goods
right let's suppose Toys R Us has a
display billboard ad in streets in
newspapers everywhere because it's
December right they think that we have a
lot of inventory that we want to sell
and so we're going to make really really
creative ads and put them across on all
areas clearly they might find that their
ads did really well and sales shut up
compared to the last month so one answer
is the creative was really good so we
should reward our designers another
answer could be that people got a lot of
interest in toys because of these ads so
ads are really effective but then if you
think just a little bit more it doesn't
take a lot you probably realize that
December is when most of us buy toys
because it's holiday season and we
go and give toys to kids so what might
just be happening is that irrespective
of the intent irrespective of the ad
irrespective of the creative it's just
that if you show ads in December or if
you do anything in December your clicks
and your purchases are going to go up
right so what you might be doing well
off is actually comparing it to December
of the last year or maybe doing
something more competitive than just
comparing it the last month or a week
before and so really if you think about
these cases you might be still wondering
that it's just we just overestimate
right there is an effect I believe
there's an effect we just overestimate
maybe it's okay right well let me show
you something else it's it's not just
that we overestimate our we
underestimate if we are not careful we
can gain completely wrong conclusions
and and this is the point that surprised
me as well this was a study we did on
reddit which I'll show you which was
just it took us weeks to understand what
was happening but once we got it it was
clear that it was another problem of
causal inference and we just got
entangled into reading too much in the
observed error how does this happen
let's suppose you want to evaluate a new
recommendation system or really any new
algorithm right and the only thing you
have is fast observational data so you
can't do an experiment right so you
think okay maybe there are other ways to
figure it out and so you what you might
do is you have algorithm a you have
algorithm B very carefully you can
sample past impressions of both
algorithms right so you have the first
algorithm which predicts recommendations
and then you have the second algorithm
protract recommendations and you can
look at the CTR so you might find that
the old algorithm on thousand
impressions does 5% CTR
very nice the new algorithm does 5.4 and
so that's a very nice result which is
telling you that algorithm B is better
and so you go to the decision makers and
tell them that yes you should continue
with algorithm B because in the observed
logs of the system this clearly has a
bigger effect but then they might ask
you that's great but we also want to
know how this algorithm is affecting
different kinds of people so for example
they might know in their domain that
higher activity people actually
contribute a lot to their platform than
lower activity people so they just want
to know how this new algorithm is
affecting different segments of people
so you say well great you go back to
your data set you segment the users into
higher activity and lower activity and
you look at the CTR and here's what you
find for lower activity users the CTR
for the old algorithm is better and for
higher activity users the CTR is again
better for the old algorithm now at this
point you might be wondering that I'm
just making some error in computing
what's going on but really that this is
all I'm doing I just had thousand
impressions I looked at the total CDR
which is right at the bottom it's out of
thousand 50 clicks out of thousand fifty
four clicks for algorithm B this is
better right and just when a condition
on higher activity and lower activity I
find exactly the opposite result so for
old algorithm I find in both cases the
CTR is better any guesses on what's
going on or what might be the problem
here
and so one one hint you might get is
that these numbers look really different
right so somehow for the new algorithm
the higher activity users got almost 80%
of the views and somehow for the lower
activity users it was the reverse right
so double the number of users were
seeing the old algorithm versus the new
algorithm right so this is this should
give you some hints that what was
happening was that just this sort of
selection effect where the people who
are likely to click more the higher
activity users somehow always went into
the condition for the new algorithm and
the people who were clicking less
somehow always went to the old algorithm
right and just because of this sort of
underlying variance in your data you
were getting completely nonsensical
results and the sort of unsatisfying
part is that even after discovering this
you might be tempted to think that
actually the old algorithm is now better
but I don't think even that's true
because what might be happening is that
we control for the activity level right
so again if you look at this diagram we
were supposing to get this effect so
recommendation algorithm to CTR
we got a positive effect for the new
algorithm but then we controlled for the
activity level because we thought that
would matter so we got a better result
which was that the old algorithm was
better but who knows what other things
were happening in the data right so
here's just one example maybe there was
a time of day effect as well maybe for
some reason or whatever bug or whatever
engineering building you might have
found that the time of day was also
factoring in so the new algorithm was
shown more in evenings the old algorithm
was shown more in mornings right and
it's entirely possible that if you
continued Chinon that to your resolver
flip again or maybe it'll just become
insignificant so really my point of this
is to show that there are valid methods
when we can condition on things we think
good
but really after a point it's just a
matter of knowing what your system is
with these kinds of methods the best we
can do is approximate to the truth
here's another example this is a
personal example that I found while
working on reddit and it took us weeks
as I said so I was working with a PhD
student and they took the entire reddit
data set from 2008 to 2014 right so
there's no sampling bias there is no API
restrictions we have the entire reddit
comment history of everyone who
commented at any point of mine what you
find is that if you look at the ears and
on the x axis I have the ears from 2008
it wasn't for dean the comment length is
decreasing over time and that's a sort
of purple line that's going down right
so what's happening is if you were
reddit and you were looking at the
average comment length in 2008 it was
high around 220 and if you were looking
at it at 2010 2011 it's about 180
characters per user per comment and if
you're looking at 2014 it's gone down to
170 clear cause for concern if you read
it because what's happening is that for
some reason people are just starting to
comment less and less and so we thought
of theories like maybe what's happening
is that when reddit was smaller people
felt a more sense of community so they
were commenting more and now it's just
become a big mess so people probably
don't associate depth that much with
Reddit and hands don't comment that much
they do yeah so that's the interesting
point we have the entire reddit comments
we did not take a sample so we there was
an API which could allow us to access
reddit comments and we sort of swept
through entire history so this average
is across all the comments made ever
from 2008 to 2014
right you might have like a million
comments in 100 million comments in 2014
compared like a hundred thousand in 2008
so it's not really an accurate
distribution
I see so so that's an interesting
question so yeah the question
essentially is that maybe what's
happening is that there were lesser
comments earlier on and then the
comments become more and more as you go
on so I think that would matter if the
sample was smaller but because we had
even in about 2008 and 2009 we already
had or more than a million users on
reddit so the error bars on these are
really small so you can essentially plot
this mean with the error bars and they
are almost indistinguishable so that
could have been happening but at least
at Reddit scale it's very unlikely that
was the case but then we found something
else and by the way if you have any
questions feel free to just jump in yeah
just switch to a mobile app which
reduces your mode of commerce needles
yes and and that's a good suggestion
yeah so maybe that was happening and and
this is the sort of thing that is so
interesting about these problems is that
we can come up with a lot of theories
but it's just hard to know what was
actually going on right but let me show
you another plot which might help us
gain some understanding so what we did
then was instead of looking at the
overall comment history we just picked
each user whenever they joined reddit
and just plotted how their average
comment length is increasing over time
right so what I'm showing you now here
is time in user referential which
essentially means if you join in 2008
you start from here if you join into
2014 the graph still starts from here it
just starts at a different level right
and what we find is that for every user
for every year that they joined their
comment length is increasing right the
only difference is that people who
joined earlier in 2008 would start at a
much higher level they would already be
commenting much more and they would sort
of then increase their level of
commenting as they grew on the new users
for whatever reasons their millennion
or they're using a mobile app they were
just using starting from less comments
per post increasing still but just
starting from less common post and
that's all that was happening right so
it was it wasn't that read it had to
discover a new way of making people want
to comment more people anyways were once
they started from whatever level they
had they were always going towards a
plot a tone of commenting more and more
and more so the problem wasn't they
wanted to comment more the problem was
just the selection effect the new users
who are coming in but somehow just not
in a style of commenting more right and
so once you discover this your solution
may be very different from what you
might might be if you thought the
comment length of the problem right
in simple terms what people in the
social sciences say is happening is
selection bias in other words the
population of people that come in each
year is changing and there's only so
much you can do except know exactly what
kinds of people you're targeting and
what kinds of strategies may work for
them and so the first part of the talks
really I guess makes the point that
making sense of data can be just too
complex even if you have millions of
users even if we have billions of
impressions there are some key
fundamental problems that cannot be
inferred just from a lot of data and so
then the logical question then becomes
how do we then reason about these kinds
of paradoxes right and the good news is
that people across different Sciences
have spent a lot of time on this even
before we had so much data they were
philosophers like Aristotle and Hume who
were sort of thinking about what does it
mean to cause something like what is it
that we want to know when we say we want
to discover the cause or we want to know
the scientific understanding for some
effect and this sort of applies in
medicines if you have a drug you want to
know how well this drug does all you get
to know is all you get to see is sick
patients going to hospitals and getting
drugs in the social do you want to know
how well your economic policies are
doing would make
the exchange rate higher or lower make
your economy better or not happy to do
an experiment but most likely people
won't allow you to do it and then
similarly in genetics you want to find
what's the effect of genes under C so
there's just lots of examples not just
non line systems but almost every part
of science which thankfully has
contributed to us to our understanding
so I'm wondering the details there are
two very very well-established
frameworks
the first one is causal graphical models
which we were using because we were sort
of looking at each of these effects in
terms of graphs and there's also
potential outcomes frameworks if you're
interested you can sort of go into
details of how it works
I'm gonna give examples so for us it's
not a philosophical question
we are very practical this is the data
engineers conference so we just have a
very practical causal meaning we want to
know if X causes Y whenever change in X
causes necessarily a change in Y and
then all you want to estimate is the
magnitude by which Y changes so if X is
your new algorithm or X's are your new
UI we just want to know how much the
standing x cause a change in Y which
would not have happened if you hadn't
changed X simple definition and so what
it'll force us now to do is to think in
terms of counterfactuals and this
personally I found the most important
concept to think of these problems is
whenever you make a decision or whenever
you're thinking of improving something
just think of the question what would
have happened if you did not do that or
what would have happened if you actually
did that and maybe increase the
intensity or decrease the intensity and
once we ask these what-if questions it
becomes much clearer about what exactly
are we doing and also how much do we
think practically it's going to have an
effect
so what's comes I'll just try to explain
the power of these methodologies using
two separate examples the first one
would be can you evaluate the impact
right so so you can think of two
questions so one is that you just want
to know there's something in the world
like a recommendation system you just
want to know how much effect it's having
right because that will help you decide
how much resources to put in that then
there are other things that you want to
may want to do is that you may want to
design a recommender system in a way
that it takes causal influence
principles into account right so the
first part I'm just going to say if you
already have an existing system how do
you evaluate and then we'll go to how do
you then just design something from
causal principles because I think that's
exactly what a lot of us should be doing
it just becomes very hard to do it so
why does it become so hard I've already
given some examples but I think this
picture really this cartoon gets to the
heart of it here's the problem we have
an old algorithm or we have an old
policy and it gives us some outcome
number of clicks we then think well
change the algorithm we change the
algorithm we get new recommendations we
get better clicks but we don't solve the
problem because our question wasn't to
compare the new from the old above a
question was really to compare if you
had the new algorithm and in a
counterfactual world where you did not
have a new algorithm what was the
difference right so if this was Toys R
Us
they had their clicks in November and
they had their new clicks in December
but really I want to know what were the
clicks in a different world a different
counterfactual world where they cloned
their customers and then showed them
nothing in December that's what I want
to know and you can clearly see it
requires changing laws of physics to
actually estimate these effects so what
people have done is and I'm sure all of
you are familiar with our a/b tests
right you say and cannot clone users but
what we can do is randomly assign what
people see doing in these different
conditions and the argument is that as
long as your coin is random if you show
some users a new algorithm if you show
some users the old algorithm on average
there's nothing different between random
user one and random user two so it's all
good
and this works brilliantly and across
all different concepts but the only
problem is that experiments are hard to
do and sometimes there are just
infeasible so think of an experiment to
determine if a subscriber on Amazon or
Netflix actually shops more or watches
more videos the only way to do an
experiment like this is to artificially
make some people subscribers who are not
and artificially make some people are
subscribers nonsubscribers right and and
you can go imagine going to Amazon and
asking them to do this real Amazon Prime
and see the reaction right so then you
need to have some other method of doing
this another thing that comes up is that
it may just be unethical right
suppose your amazon and you want to find
out the subscription price for Amazon
Prime should it be 99 dollars should it
be $80 should be fifty dollars one
simple issue an experiment that's what
economists would tell you but what you
would not expect is that a lot of
customers may lose faith in you because
just because of random chance some had
to pay much more for membership some had
to pay much less for membership and then
it can also sort of just be inconvenient
if you're showing like a UI element it
can just drive it away if it doesn't
work right
so then the natural question becomes
what can you do with just observational
data I showed some examples where you
can just keep conditioning so if you
have very good idea of how your system
was built hopefully because you built it
then you can keep on conditioning on
things that you think I'm good matter
like activity level time of day so on
but it's sort of a rabbit hole I mean
you can always approximate the truth
you'll never be able to get to the truth
the other approach and this is sort of
recent research work that's been
developing is that you can somehow find
randomized experiments in the
observational data and so the basic
approach is that we can't do experiments
but what we can do is find as if random
events that happen in the data set that
you're interested in so here for example
if you want to calculate the effect of a
recommendation what you can do is that
you can exploit some naturally occurring
variation like
Jon Stewart suggesting a book on his
show right what will that do is that
it'll create the sort of an artificial
shock to your book system or a book
website and then you can just see how
much of that flows through the
recommendation system to other books
right so instead of doing an experiment
where you sort of artificially put a lot
of users in one condition where they had
to see a book and see the effect on
recommendations you can use Jon Stewart
Oprah Winfrey anyone who just creates
these unnatural conditions in your data
set but then helps you to see the
spillover effect on recommendations and
it turns out that these external shocks
can be used to estimate the
counterfactual because it's pretty clear
that if Jon Stewart had not sent a lot
of people to this book page it is very
unlikely that they would have also
clicked on to the recommendation to the
recommended books without the
recommendation system right make sense
except there was no recommendation
people would have only seen the first
book because of recommendations they saw
other books and so you can estimate the
effect that way and here's again the
causal graphical model you can actually
prove it but I'm just going to a
schematic in general visits to a book or
an app are just confounded because
Wizards can cause recommendation clicks
but just demand in itself is correlated
right because that's exactly why you
were recommending them in the first
place the Wizards could happen anyways
right the nice thing is that when you
have a certain shock what happens is
these visits become very high right so
suppose this was your first product app
one that had a spike a huge increase in
traffic and you can make a clear case
that if demand for app two remains
constant then additional views to Abdul
would not have happened without this
recommendation system that was actually
just showing people recommendations to
click on all right so this based on this
very intuitive strategy you can have a
method that describes this effect and
this is just detail you can actually
just show that this effect would be
equal and to the effect
of removing the recommendations from
that page and comparing those to
counterfactuals but then the problem is
and I think as some of you might also
think is that this is a very odd
approach like this you're sort of taking
these very very odd things that happen
in your data set and computing something
on those small set of shocks right so in
some sense it may not be as satisfying
so what you can do is then you can try
to increase the breadth of what you can
do but really the upshot is that if it's
possible do randomization but if it's
not then you can consider these creative
methods of finding experiments in your
data and in fact what I've been finding
in my recent research and I have some
papers at the end is that you can
actually do this in a data mining way
you can sort of just use an algorithm to
find these unnatural effects but in some
sense it still is unsatisfying because
now we know that this recommendation
system may not be working as well or
maybe it's working great but then what
do we do with it how do we come up with
a new better algorithm that should
replace it right and here I think
there's been a lot of work which shows
that what you should really do is just
think of systems as continuous
experiments and what what this means is
that let me take an example of gambling
if you've gone to these casinos what you
would find are these sort of slots in
the casinos and you just pick one slot
at random you get some reward right now
assuming you were an algorithm right
what you might think of it is that
whenever I pick one slot which is I show
one recommendation I get some reward
it's a click or it's not a click right
so what you can just do is over a period
of time you can just randomly select
different of these arms and figure out
which arm works the best right so so
it's this sort of requires a change in
the way we think about algorithms
because what this thing is that there's
no one code algorithm and maybe it's not
worthwhile to find one go that guard we
should really be doing is that we have a
list of items to recommend
what we're gonna do is we're gonna just
randomly recommend maybe each of these
items in turn and then find which ones
people like and which kinds of people
like which items and as we learn that we
are going to keep showing more and more
of that strategy and less and less of
the other strategies that we tried out
and it sort of keeps playing on so the
most simplest algorithm that you could
implement with such kind of an approach
would be bandits and what this does is
the old algorithm was showing you some
recommendations it says I don't trust
this algorithm I would not even trust a
new algorithm that comes in its place so
here's what I do I would show whatever I
think is the best algorithm right now to
most of the users and then I'm going to
show whatever is a random algorithm
completely arbitrary the rest of the
users right and the idea is that by
showing the right algorithm to most
people you're exploiting right and this
is the world we are always in we are
always exploiting we predict well and we
show people always that but then we also
have this exploration here which is
saying that that algorithm is great but
I'm just going to test new strategies
random strategies on other people and
you can again theoretically show that if
you always do this you can sort of have
a feedback loop where this strategy
informs your current best algorithm and
it sort of keeps on improving every day
every second
and as simplest algorithm for this would
be something like this with low
probability you show a completely random
item to a user this is where you're
learning and with high probability you
show the current best output from the
algorithm and then essentially if you
want to think of it in some sense your
system is learning as it's proceeding so
instead of having a train test it's sort
of learning with as it gets new I new
items it tests on its users and then
feedbacks in to the actual algorithm and
this is also practical just like the
last one was used successfully on
Amazon's recommendation this is being
used on MSN
for example here this is Yahoo homepage
and there's a paper that shows how this
can work for showing different news
articles as recommendations and finally
I just want to close with a very very
strong warning in the last two parts of
the top I presented two methods that
work well and so you might get the
impression that if you're using those
methods you'll be doing mostly correct
in terms of causal inference but I would
be a little skeptic for this graph and I
think that if one thing that you want to
take from the stock I would prefer that
you just take this graph in your heads
and this graph is very compelling
because it shows that computer science
doctorates awarded in the US and the
number of revenue generated by our kids
is almost perfectly correlated and you
might just say oh that's that's not
right that doesn't make sense but we
know this because we have some sense of
what's going on here we know that well
we hope that computer science PhD
students are not motivated by our kids
but this could be any time series right
this could be any two variables in your
data set and if you're not careful and
if you don't have an intuition on what's
going on
you've been you'll be in trouble trying
to interpret these things and also
predicting based on these things and so
really always be skeptical of causal
claims from observational data actually
from any data and then another thing
which is quite true is that more data
may not necessarily improve your causal
effects it might just make you more sure
of wrong results and that's it thank you
[Applause]
we have time for one or two questions if
anyone has them I can bring the mic over
to you yeah I just wondering you mention
enroll at ETA Hyatt 850 how did you
define you mentioned a high activity and
a low activity how did you define a low
and high like that I see so the question
was in the example for recommendations
we divided people into higher activity
and lower activity that was just based
on what the people in the property were
using already so it was essentially if I
remember correctly 10% of the users were
higher activity users and everything
else was no activity but but I think the
larger point is that the specifics do
not matter that much because you can
also imagine another study where you do
20% where you do 30% right I think Ian's
site for us was that it changes and
flips based on what you select but it
you can use any cutoff how long should
you run the the multi-armed bandit you
can call it a explore exploit how long
should you explore for and then exploit
like with that so you avoid some kind of
stigma OG or something like so I think
the the question was in multi armed
bandits expert proach how long should
you keeping on exploring exploit I think
that really depends on how important do
you think is getting the right answer
but maybe another approach is to think
of a case where these distributions are
keeping on changing over time right so
maybe the right answer is to just say
that I'm going to run this always and
the only thing I'm going to change based
on my confidence is the percentage of
time and exploring and the person is
just time exploiting but I think it's
sort of requires a key philosophical
shift all almost in the way we think
about algorithms because first it needs
some humility to know that you don't
have the best algorithm and second it's
this sort of weird scenario where each
every day is an experiment going on and
it's sort of a self learning system but
I think it's really important because in
some cases it might be not
that interesting for example if you're
trying to predict someone's credit
history it's not changing day after day
but think of if you're trying to predict
cases like what people like in music
right or what people are trying to do
with news these things change very
quickly so what's interesting today may
not be interesting tomorrow so it it
doesn't make any sense to say that the
prediction algorithm was working
yesterday would also sort of keep
working as people's preferences change
so maybe the answer is to sort of always
to explore explain